on a très peu de précision à un quant au
planning de cette visite de l'oeil à ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'ils sont
partis de kiev ce matin très tôt qu'ils
vont sans doute arrivé ici à zaporizhya
il ya 550 km entre les deux villes à la
mi journée ensuite la partie commence
compliqué de ce voyage va commencer ils
vont d'abord devoir passer la ligne de
front pour rentrer en territoire occupé
par les russes et là ils vont devoir
aller jusqu'à la centrale nucléaire qui
se trouve à environ 60 kilomètres à vol
d'oiseau de l'endroit où je me tiens une
fois sur place la visite doit durer
plusieurs jours a fait le gros si
clairement laissé entendre qu'il
souhaitait mettre en place une mission
permanente dans cette centrale la plus
grande d'europe qui se trouve à l'heure
actuelle sur une ligne de front pour
l'instant les russes n'ont pas accepté
cette idée ce qu'on sait en tout cas
c'est que cette visite va durer
plusieurs jours plusieurs jours pour
déterminer l'état structurel de la
station pour vérifier le fonctionnement
des mécanismes de sécurité et puis pour
voir dans quelles conditions travaillent
le millier d'ingénieurs ukrainiens qui
sont encore sur le site qui font tourner
cette centrale sous commandement russes
et les ukrainiens disent qu'ils sont mal
traités qu'ils sont forcés de travailler
et bien ce sont autant de choses que
vont pouvoir vérifier cette délégation
de les yeux alors les deux camps
s'accusent mutuellement de provocation
aux alentours de la centrale et il y a
eu effectivement des tirs d'artillerie
hier soir l'équipe ici s'est couché au
son d'une sirène anti bombes on s'est
réveillé également avec une sirène donc
effectivement toujours de l'artillerie
dans le secteur hier nous nous sommes
rendus à nikopol avec wassim ben ali est
là et bien nous n'avons pas été
autorisés à rentrer dans la vie il
s'agit de la ville qui se trouve
directement à l'opposé de l'autre côté
du nieppe face à la centrale on nous a
expliqué que c'était trop dangereux
nous avons entendu des départs de feu de
tirs d'artillerie ukrainien et nous
avons pu parler à une partie de la
population qui se réfugient dans les
villages à proximité nikopol notamment
un homme dont donc qui a eu un grade qui
est tombé dans son jardin de sa maison
de nikopol qui nous expliquer eh bien
ces gens là qu'ils avaient trop peur de
dormir en ville et qu'il préférait se
réfugier dans les bois la maire du
village nous a expliqué qu'ils étaient
plusieurs centaines à le faire chaque
jour